it began with the newspaper article of a
woman who was evicted from her house for
failure to pay back taxes she said she
didn't know what the houses repossessed
they evicted or sold it off and then
discovered they had the wrong house this
happens a lot there was a computer snafu
yet the man who bought it in a fair and
square legal auction was under no legal
pressure to buy back or to sell it back
and he wasn't sure he wanted to in this
real article and I saw it the man's name
was Arabic and it wasn't Persian but
earlier in my life I'd known a Persian
man who was a colonel in the Shahs Air
Force who found himself in the United
States working 16-hour days in menial
jobs he was working in a gas station for
the first eight hours and then in a shoe
factory and he said to me once he you
know that he used to work with kings and
queens and presidents and vice
presidents of entire countries by
himself and now he serves candy and
cigarettes to kids who don't even know
who I am he said and I never forgot it
and so when I saw that middle-eastern
name in that newspaper article about
that woman's house I I began to wonder
well what if my colonel bought that
house and that began the book you see I
mean for me that the whole fuel for
writing fiction is is curiosity it's not
it's not what I know but what I don't
know and and that's what drives that's
what actually what doesn't drive me it
actually pulls me into story right
but you know what it was actually I was
the first writing class I'd ever taught
I didn't even have a writing degree and
I was trying to get 22 18 year old
started and I said hey look look look at
the newspaper there's some good stuff in
here
and then I pointed to that story and
read it out loud to them so you guys
should write about this but no one took
me up on it thank God because I cut it
out and I I did it I try not to think
too much in the first job of writing
novel I try to do it the the writer
Richard bow encouraged Richard box had a
great line he said if you think that you
are thinking when you're writing think
again you're much closer to the dream
inside of your brain so I try to dream
it through and and and I try to write as
truly as I possibly can and I found over
the years that if you just do that
you'll end up saying something you
didn't know you were trying to say or
that the novel of the story was trying
to say one of the things that I came
away with from writing House of Sand and
Fog is that it's so easy to misbehave in
this world you know it's so you know
when we're up against it it's it's
really hard to do the right thing I
really think maybe the Saints among us
are the ones who who are suffering in
some way financially health-wise
whatever and yet they're still loving
people I think a lot of us tend to be
when we're up against it not as loving
as we could be in fact I think we we
misbehave quite a bit another thing that
I think is in that novel House of Sand
and Fog is this notion that it's awfully
easy to assume we know the other and
when we don't and I think that
assumption that prejudging leads to all
sorts of conflict
well that novel House of Sand and Fog
got a lot of calls from the film world
my agent got over 140 calls in a year
and a half and every now and then he
would forward to me somebody he thought
might have a shot at making the movie
and anyway all those conversations Sean
into the same way they would say some
nice things about the drama bah bah bah
then they'd say but we have to soften
the ending and they almost always use
that verb and I said well what do you
mean soften the ending so well you know
it's a downer I said well yeah it's a
tragedy they're they're Downers I will
politely hang-up and then one day I got
a call from this Ukrainian man vadim
perelman who hadn't made a feature film
but he had some backing and my agent had
a feeling about him we had a really good
talk and and towards the end of it he
said you know listen some some big
Hollywood person may give you a lot of
money and make your book into a film but
these were his exact words he said but
they're gonna take your baby they're
gonna chain it to the radiator and
they're gonna rape and kill it
and so what are you gonna do he said I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna hurt your baby
you wrote a dark book I'm gonna make a
dark film it'll be in art houses and no
one's gonna go see it that's what you're
my man I gave him the option that day so
he kept me in the loop more than you
know fiction writers are normally kept
in the loop and and I'm ultimately very
pleased with what he did I think it's
very loyal to the feeling of the book I
was particularly pleased to see that he
was really respectful of the Iranian
family as you know I mean that this has
been change in the last 10 or 15 years
but Middle Eastern people tend to be put
into two or three types and he didn't do
that
was gratifying for me to see